-I'm a big fan of your work
and I'm so happy to meet you.
-Well, likewise.
-You're a stud.
Everyone loves ya. Yeah.
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]
-Flattery will get you
everywhere.
-Yeah. I want to talk
about "House of the Dragon,"
but I also want to talk
about, on "The Crown,"
-Whoo!
-you played Prince -- Yeah.
I mean, oh, my God.
Prince Philip.
[ Cheering and applause ]
You did such a great job
as Prince Philip.
-Thank you.
Nominated for awards
and all this stuff.
-Yeah.
Always the bridesmaid.
I never win.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
It's cooler
to just be nominated.
-Is it?
-Yeah.
-You've won loads,
though, ain't ya?
-No, I've never been nominated.
-What?!
[ Laughter ]
-But I'm just saying.
But it sounds cool.
Did you ever meet any
of the royals
-[ Inhales sharply ]
-or did you meet the queen?
-I met Harry.
No, I mean not the queen.
I met Harry. I met William.
I met now-King Charles.
-Wow!
-Yeah, he came to "Doctor Who."
He was impeccably dressed.
And I went,
"You're very well-dressed,"
and he went, "No, no,
you're very well-dressed."
And I went,
"You've got marvelous shoes."
He went, "Actually, you've got
marvelous shoes."
And I went, "They're red,"
and he went,
"But yours are red."
-Wow!
-And I went,
"How long have you had yours?"
And he said, "35 years."
[ Laughter ]
-No!
Thirty-five years.
-He had his shoes for 35 years?
-Yeah.
You'd think, as a king,
he'd be able to, you know...
-Yeah, exactly.
-...afford a new pair of boots,
you know what I mean?
-Get a new pair of shoes.
Uh --
-Oh, yes!
-Lookit, this is a photo
of you guys in front of the --
-No, I look like
I've won a prize.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Do you know what I mean?
Or like I've ran in and gone,
"Yeah, mate."
[ Laughter ]
-How cool is that?
-What?!
-Did you get nervous?
Did you know that he was coming
and was it a big deal?
-Yeah, yeah.
They sort of lay out
the red carpet and all that.
-Of course.
-Yeah, but he was only
a prince then,
so he was like small,
he was small-fry.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, yeah, at that point.
Now, he's king, yeah, he's like,
"Do you remember me?"
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Yeah, of course.
-Can we talk
about "House of the Dragon"?
-Yeah, yeah.
-Congrats.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Thank you, brother.
-Giant hit.
You're awesome in it.
You're really good in it.
-Thank you very much.
-I have questions about where
-It's very cult.
-your character goes.
[ Laughter ]
I'm not completely caught up
as everyone else.
Don't worry about it, yeah.
-Yeah? Okay, good.
-Don't bother.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, eventually,
you have to get caught up.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Yeah, but not right now,
don't worry about it?
But can you set up
where it takes place
or when it takes place?
-[ Inhales sharply ]
-Yeah.
So, it takes place 175 years?
-Yes.
-Is that right? Is that right?
Before "Game of Thrones"...
-That's correct.
-...that show.
And it's about a sort of,
you know, incestuous, volatile,
sociopathic family
[ Laughter ]
...with blond wigs
-With blond wigs, yeah.
-who ride dragons and, you know,
get cross with each other.
-By the way, you pull off
the hair very well.
-Do you think?
-Oh!
Look at this.
Are you kidding?
[ Cheering and applause ]
-I know like some angles,
like I'm good from the sides.
It's quite a lot from the front,
I think.
-No, you look cool.
That's the first thing I said
-Well, that's a good one.
-when I saw you. I go,
"He's pulling this off."
You look really cool.
-Oh, cheers.
-And then you actually --
Well, everyone kind of
has this hair, kind of.
-Yeah, exactly, yeah, you know.
-A lot of people have
this style of hair.
-It takes ages to put
the wig on.
It's a [bleep] nightmare.
-But then you --
[ Laughter ]
But then you skip ahead in time
-Yeah.
-and you have short hair --
-Yeah. Yeah. Which I think
looks a bit better.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-That's -- That's -- That's what
I'm talking about here.
-[ Laughs ]
-Everyone is still talking
about you had --
This is Episode 3,
which I've seen.
-Yeah.
-I think there's only four out,
but I'm up to Episode 3
and you had an epic battle.
I'll just say that.
I don't want to spoil anything.
-Yeah, yeah.
-But let's just say this --
the Internet went nuts
because you have an epic battle.
No dialogue in this battle.
-Yes.
-But people think that you
should win an award just
for the scene...
-Well.
-...even that you had
no dialogue,
you spoke with your acting.
-It's when I'm at my best,
actually,
when I don't speak, essentially.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, but I mean,
this was the real deal.
-It's when I come alive.
-It really is when, yeah, yeah.
I wish you just came out tonight
and just didn't say anything.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, me too, actually.
-Yeah, yeah.
-I've been [bleep] meself
all day.
-No.
[ Laughter ]
But you do this and I go,
"Oh, this guy knows how
to do it,"
because you're just
a great actor.
-Aw, Jimmy.
-But I mean, do you know
how to fight?
-Not really.
I mean, I had a great stuntman.
And then, yeah, you know,
you train,
you do all that stuff,
you swing a sword,
then you get there and you,
you know,
pray and hope for the best.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Do a few rolls, you know,
pretty faces where you grimace.
-Yeah, no,
but you do it so well.
And then, also, you speak
another language in this.
-Yes, High Valyrian.
-High Valyrian is
-Yes, yes.
-the name of the, yeah.
-Is the language, yeah.
Which, I mean, I can --
[ Speaking High Valyrian ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
[Bleep]
[ Laughter ]
[ Rimshot ]
-Now, that --
play that backwards, it says,
"Paul is dead," yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, yeah, yeah. It says,
"Jimmy, you've got
glorious eyes."
-Yeah!
Can I --
Can you teach me to say that?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
"Nu hosso demat."
-"Nu hosso demat."
-Whoa! Yeah, that's good, bro.
-That was good?
[ Laughter ]
That's a good start.
-Really?
-Yeah.
-I've never done this.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
"Keh see nu hohss."
-"Keh see nu hohss."
-"Deh mih voss."
-Mazilarios.
Mazilarios.
-Seenaloose.
-[Bleep], yeah.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
-Say that.
-Yeah, I can say that.
[ Cheering ]
And, actually, it means --
-No, wait, what did I just say?
-It means -- It means,
"One day,
this chair will be mine."
[ Oohs, cheering, and applause ]
Although, I'd butcher your job,
in truth.
I couldn't do it.
I'd be terrible.
-Yeah, you can do it.
You can do anything you want.
You have your own dragon.
What are we talking about?
Come on, bud.
-True enough, true enough.
-What is your dragon's name,
again?
-He's called Caraxes
and he's sort of --
he's like an avatar of Daemon,
really.
He's really grumpy,
volatile, cynical.
-Do you act with a like
-A real dragon.
-a tennis ball on a stick or --
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, no, it's like a --
I mean, well, so like they build
like a plinth, basically,
which is like 20 foot in the air
and it's like a kind of
bucking bronco in a boozer,
you know, in a pub.
-Yeah.
-And then they like --
[ Laughter ]
there's a guy
with a remote control.
He's like moving it around.
He's really pleased
with his life, obviously,
because he's moving you around.
-It's a great gig.
-It's a great job, isn't it?
-Oh, my gosh!
-Yeah, and he probably
hates you.
He's like -- And I'm like,
"Go faster, mate!"
And then, you know,
they fire loads of --
-Oh, so you're riding on it.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah,
like a bronco.
-Oh, wow!
-Yeah, yeah.
And then they fire wind and rain
and then after 10 hours, you're
like, "Get me the [bleep] off."
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God.
Got to watch your mouth
on this show.
Sorry, I know.
-It's unbelievable.
-Oh, God, yeah.
We can't swear, can we?
-No.
Sorry.
Sorry, America.
Can they bleep me out?
-The king is watching!
He will be so upset!
-He will be.
-With his 35-year-old shoes.
-I know.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I think you're a great actor
and I'm just a fan of yours.
I'm so happy that you came
on our show.
-Thank you.
-Congrats with the new show.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Matt Smith
in "House of the Dragon."
Take a look at this.
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Drumbeat ]
-[Indistinct]
-Of course, my prince.
♪♪
-Come on, right there.
That's how you do it.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Matt Smith, everyone.
Matt Smith!
New episodes
of "House of the Dragon"
air Sundays on HBO.
We'll be right back
with Sheryl Crow.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Stick around.